diront quoi dire pour nous pour nous
tous que nous sommes trahis alors que je
pense qu'on fait partie des privilégiés
il faut avoir un peu quand même de
retenue en revanche chez les français
est pas venu en revanche en revanche moi
je vous le dis je pense effectivement
comme au zinc ci a pas trahison il ya un
gouvernement qui en ressort
moi quand j'entends le le débat sur les
premiers de cordée au début du mandat et
quand je vois comment ce mandat se
termine je me dis que mon nez c'est du
foutage de gueule il ya des français qui
se lèvent le matin qui sont à 1200 euros
par mois
honnêtement comment on vit avec 1200
euros par mois dans notre grand pays
aujourd'hui n'oublie pas il faut qu'on
pose une question simple qu'on y réponde
sa démagogie sans parti pris qu'on soit
de gauche de droite du centre comment on
vit avec 1200 euros dans notre pays
aujourd'hui de surcroît avec une
situation qui fait que les prix de
l'électricité explose le prix du
carburant explose les matières premières
comme tu va bouffer des pâtes parce que
tu as une famille de 4 à la maison
augmente un moment donné va falloir
qu'on arrête parce qu'on peut pas dire
valeur travail il faut se lever le matin
les français sont des feignants nous
font ne sont même pas plus qu'ils
travaillent en lots - et un moment donné
faire en sorte que le travail soit aussi
peu récompensés donc le premier sujet
aujourd'hui qui préoccupent les français
à l'aune de ces présidentielles c'est de
pouvoir d'achat c'est pas une migration
comme certains joueurs
mais heureusement alors une fin de mois
digne ne pas être à découvert le 10 du
mois voilà et pouvoir penser à un avenir
pour ces enfants les jeunes demandent
pas plus que ça voilà et ça aujourd'hui
c'est pas sur la table du débat
politique on nous fait chier toute la
journée avec les musulmans les banlieues
l'immigration comme si c'était le
premier majeur du pays moi je veux bien
qu'on me parle de l'islam des banlieues
de l'immigration j'ai pas de problème
avec ça mais parlons quand même du
projet du du sujet majeur c'est le bon
vieux aujourd'hui monsieur le député je
voulais parce que vous êtes là pour
représenter la majorité très sincèrement
vous pouvez nous dire donc que les
impôts les impôts locaux les revenus
l'impôt sur le revenu a baissé moi je
vous parle pas de ça les gens qui gagne
1200 euros via paypal et me posent sur
leur domaine je vous parle pas de ça je
vous parle de ceux aujourd'hui qui
bossent et qui arrive pas à vivre non
j'ai pas monsieur même plus à construire
un pays qui a un avenir et qui est une
espérance si quand tu te lèves le matin
tu ne peux pas te nourrir mais c'est pas
moi qu'il faut dire ça j'ai vécu
longtemps avec moi au moins je
sais qui je suis agriculteur le délégué
pour moi il le sera pendant les
nombreuses années c'est ce n'est pas
satisfaisant si et c'est pour ça que
dans la première intervention j'ai parlé
pouvoir d'achat et l'augmentation des
salaires j'en ai parlé dans la première
partie parce que effectivement toute
façon que ce soit 100 200 ça ne suffira
pas une aide à domicile qui va s'occuper
des personnes âgées au fin fond de la
creuse qui gagnent à peine 1000 euros
100 euros c'est pas rien déjà pour
commencer c'est pas rien mais c'est à
franck pour couvrir et pour vivre ça on
est bien d'accord j'ai donc c'est parce
que vous êtes accord apporte une réponse
avec ce gouvernement est
là dessus
on à augmenter le smic alors certes pas
dans les proportions sans doute qu'il
aurait fallu faire mais il faut que les
entreprises puissent payer parce que
facet aux chefs d'entreprise que je vais
expliquer que l'augmentation du smic
derrière ça a des conséquences sur les
artisans les bêtes mais le bcbh lait
mais les charges mais oui mais si vous
augmentez le smic c'est tous les
salaires augmentent donc il faut que les
patrons aient les moyens de payer c'est
pour ça qu'on a essayé de réduire les
impôts sur les entreprises
certain nombre de deux de nos
concurrents politiques pour essayer
justement de libérer conflits
d'entreprise puisse payer davantage
leurs salariés et c'est le cas déjà dans
la restauration parce qu'aujourd'hui
dans la restauration si elles payent pas
davantage les salariés elles ont plus de
salariés parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans des situations de chômage a baissé
qu'on le veuille ou non il a baissé et
aujourd'hui il ya une population active
qui est moins importante qu'elle a pu
l'être par passé et aujourd'hui dans la
restauration on a augmenté les salaires
dans leur
antre pas demandeur
je suis tp ont tous parlent mais ne
voyez pas que les gens de leur
travail mérite salaire